news Tai Lopez you hear about this yeah
going he's going jail
yeah what
cannibal
[Laughter]
here my garage we have all these kids
that we eat him and uh
who's the the Grant Cardone Grant
Cardone oh yeah yeah he's also a
cannibal yeah yeah well they're part of
like the like hustle guy Elite yeah that
are all secretly cannibals yeah yeah
yeah they're like the Illuminati of
hustle culture guys they just want to
eat people people
he bought Radio Shacks so he could eat
all the employees
because they're old as hell so he's like
they'll be easy to break down No One's
Gonna Miss You yeah
everyone forgot about you already
yeah the first thing people say when
they're like yeah he was eating Radio
Shack employees the first thing they say
is Go Radio Shack is still open
yeah but no he's a distraction yeah he's
eating the employees I didn't even know
they still employ people oh
where was it because I didn't see no no
the ones in my city closed they're like
eating like the remnant employees that's
great I used to get batteries there
just buy like little RC cars there when
I was a kid it's crazy it's so much fun
yeah all the ones in my city close
that's because the people were eaten
yeah well I mean you can't keep his door
open with no employees so
I guess it makes sense
no like Tai Lopez Cuts away yeah oh yeah
I know that guy is he the book guy I
he's a garage guy right oh wow
what's the garage guy Pier One too
so yeah he's going he's going B rep
yeah so this is something that he's wait
who are you thinking about you were like
oh oh uh call me by your name Army
Hammer Army also a cannibal yeah but
like
what did he say again was the famous
quote
he said like I'm Legit a cannibal
remember we were joked about that for so
long in his DMS he's like I'm
legitimately a cannibal look it up yeah
dude he says that the nerve of that guy
to come back and do an article and be
like I've Been Framed by cancel culture
I am 100 accountable don't you remember
that yeah yeah now I do no no title of
an episode is there any refuting that
yeah I mean it's like you could have
said I'm 90 accountable then there would
have been a little wiggle room
he said I am 100 a cannibal did this guy
not spend any time watching like Vice
documentaries remember that Vice talk
about that dude in Japan who's a
convicted Cannibal and he's just
roaming I never saw that yeah bro what
yeah
yeah like he why is he roaming he's just
a citizen no but like isn't it illegal
if you get convicted of
being a cannibal you get that there's
something like weird because then you
have to you would you would have had to
have killed the person right or I guess
you could like chop off their arm and
eat it
or just you know little calf a little
sliceye oh yeah I guess yeah
I forget what it was but there's some
loophole where
he is just a regular citizen
and all I'm saying is armies could have
done a little bit of research
he could have just said I want to eat
you you know yeah
it could be like a weird sexual but
there's probably like a lot of messages
before that yeah yeah yeah he probably
did say that at some point yeah and
she's like she's like yeah I want you to
eat me out and he's like not exactly
what I mean
not quite what I'm thinking yeah
I want your feet and your femur and your
kneecap and your thigh yeah you want to
kiss him I want to eat them yeah you
want to like yeah you eat it because
your toes and put them on the grill
okay like like Grill like what do you
mean
a Black and Decker
6200 is that like a dildo like a fancy
dildo no it's a black inductor you get
it from Home Depot
okay like an industrial dildo
nope I'm 100 accountable I don't think
you understand what I'm saying 100 I
want to hook up a can of propane this is
just Hank Hill well put some propane and
cut your feet off and holy [__] dude
you just live to obey and be my slave
I will own you that's my soul my brain
my spirit my body would you come and be
my property till you die
man he whatever this is a real life this
is a real life whatever his face was
from Last of Us yeah if I wanted to cut
off one of your toe oh I'm just doing
yeah
that's great well no it's not no it's
not quite so fun if I wanted to cut off
one of your toes and keep it with me in
my pocket so I will so I always had a
little piece of your dog a little piece
of you in my possession so I always had
those little piggies with me oh man you
just got a a Taxidermy pinky toe just
rolling around in his pocket yeah Tai
Lopez Tai Lopez bankrupt so he bought
Radio Shack Pier One all these like
dying retail Brands yeah
things what Linens and things yeah raise
money him and his partner like raised
like tens of millions of dollars to buy
these Brands and turn them into like
e-commerce brands or something like
modernize them yeah and for some reason
people thought like he was the one that
was gonna do this and I guess it's not
working out at all revs revenues which
ice rev is probably the company that he
formed to buy all this right the losses
were about 60 million compared with
about 150 million in sales in 2021 and
about 90 million in losses
it has racked up over 200 million
dollars in debt The Source added wow
um is Rev Radio Shack what's rev is that
there that's oh I was assuming that's
the company they is that they're like
yeah umbrella company Pat owns all these
Brands yeah
huh
that's crazy if you have a you know buy
the students program yeah exactly guys
we got to keep British like do you wanna
yeah this is Rev we transform well-known
undervalued retail Brands into
e-commerce success stories they bought
bodybuilding.com yeah but I feel like
they're not doing that bad it's probably
just like a couple really bad like it's
probably Radio Shack and Pier One that
are like taking this whole thing down
because a lot of these actually seem
like they're successful monthly
subscription businesses
yeah
Pier One if that's true Mentor box has
60 000 reoccurring Subs it's pretty
crazy just for one brand yeah when's the
last time you set foot in a Pier One Man
not since all their employees were eaten
what did beer one even what do they sell
that was the great Reckoning Reckoning
when all the retail employees got eaten
all these rich guys heard like this Eat
the Rich thing and they said nope
it'll be you before us and they ate them
all
you thought I was paying you
I'm a Munch
eat your family for dinner eat your
family for lunch
you thought I was paying you
I'm a I'm a munch
[Laughter]
your old how much your family
yeah man the cannibals love I spice they
love ice spice it's like the first song
that actually gets me
[Laughter]
oh man a cannibal a bunch all sorts of
stuff cannibal in a car with his boys
they're like
it's like [__] dude
I [__] I would much I spice yeah I
would too yeah
wait this song's about sex yeah
oh
oh sorry guys I'm 100 accountable
turns to his boy